[Musique]
Inna accompagne ces garçons à l'école
cette famille ukrainienne est arrivée à
Lévis en juin dernier un soulagement
triste c'est dangerous pour ma famille
au Canada
à la vie de l'école de la chanterelle
Robert est bien entouré de ses amis et
dans sa classe de maternelle Martine
pose fièrement avec son vêtement
traditionnel ukrainien il y aura du bon
en français comment on dit bonjour en
français Marcel bonjour
ça se passe très bien à ce moment-ci de
l'année ces formidable de voir sa
progression il est très travaillant
c'est un enfant le qui aime beaucoup
apprendre qui aime être en interaction
avec les autres enfants je pense que
c'est ce qui va pousser à apprendre son
français apprendre le français pour
communiquer s'intégrer et se faire des
amis mais aussi pour partager ce qu'on a
appris dans son pays d'origine
jusqu'à combien
aime les chiffres et a fait découvrir
pour les calculs à toute sa classe grâce
à ce boulier qui a fait le voyage avec
lui
[Musique]
ces nouveaux amis sont conscients de ce
qui se passe outre-mer
triste parce que
je serais quand même triste trop tard je
pense qu'il y aurait aimé rester à son
pays
et pour les personnes qui sont en guerre
la bouche
ils vont peut-être être mort mais
aujourd'hui Robert a décidé de célébrer
sa chance d'être ici merci à tous
[Musique]
une place touristique
ça veut dire que si je vais visiter pour
le tabac c'est un endroit à aller voir
nous voici maintenant au collège Dina
Bélanger il va discute en français avec
Ginette une bénévole qui aide à la
francisation des trois élèves que
l'école secondaire a admis en septembre
il s'agit de yeva Maria et Nikita
les premiers pas en français ont été
exigeants
en français mais maintenant on peut vous
comprendre beaucoup c'est très belle les
villages les villes
et c'est très très gentil les
gens l'accueillent ici a été
irréprochable même cet élève dans la mer
est d'origine russe est devenu leur
meilleure amie j'apprécie beaucoup leur
amitié et
c'est c'est vraiment cool maintenant
c'est un trio inséparable d'amis une
d'origine russe et deux de ukrainienne
alors pour moi c'est ce qui me dit que
l'amitié ça a pas de frontière et je
pense que les adolescents nous le prouve
malgré leur plaisir partagé une part de
même restant
[Musique]
ils espèrent tant la fin de cette guerre
un espoir cueillez va a d'ailleurs
immortalisé sur ce dessin qui est la
réalisé en arts plastiques oui c'est
difficile parce que et mon papa dans
lequel est mon ami tous les amis
j'ai pas d'accord avec la guerre et je
trouve que c'est c'est comme comment on
dit avec
on ne peut pas résoudre le mal avec du
mal
mais vite on tourne la page sur ces
cendres pensées en cette lumineuse
journée d'hiver quelle belle occasion de
s'amuser à prendre des photos entre amis
ici Guylaine Bussière Radio-Canada
Saint-Michel de Bellechasse
[Musique]